hello everyone and welcome to a game a
lot of you have requested it's from the
AI comp and it is the sixth event of
this year's Champions Chester we have a
very nice game between Vladimir kramnik
and Han smoke and Iman this is the first
game of their match and uh the basically
how it works is first player players
player nine a round Swiss tournament and
then those who did well in the Swiss
tournament uh go into matches and they
will play a two-game match if it's a
draw then of course they go into
Armageddon so this is the first game of
the match for the metacramnik versus
Hans smoke and Neiman and a lot of like
I said a lot we have requested it but
now that comic posted um this uh well he
didn't post it he basically changed his
info on chess.com into this I decided uh
to cover it so this is what uh chronic
said on his chess.com account he says I
have decided to stop playing on
chess.com from tomorrow on just too many
obvious cheaters here and nothing is
done to clean the platform from those
small Crooks harsh words but true would
continue informing those who care uh who
care publishing interesting statistics
though hope would come back one day if
it will be cleaned from at least obvious
cheaters I promise we'll continue trying
my best to save the chess from this
disease as much as I can fighting with
natural squeamishness which is the main
reason of my chess.com departure the
strength is in truth so there you have
it that is what um Vladimir wrote on his
chess.com profile page and now let's
check out the game and then let's check
out what Hans proposed to him on his uh
well I'm still going to call it Twitter
I find it really weird calling it X
maybe it will grow on MIA but I'm just
gonna go with with the Twitter for a
moment so let's check it out this is the
first game of their match Vladimir has
the white pieces and he opens with
Knight to F3 he goes for the ready
opening as you might expect from the
former world champion we have D5 by Hans
G3 Knight to C6 and now Pawn to D4 with
Bishop to F5 and now Bishop to G2 onto
E6 and Vladimir Castle so it's a pretty
standard setup of the king's Indian
attack where usually Knight to F6 is
played but Hans goes for Knight to B4
it's actually the second most popular
continuation just going after the C2
pawn and now Knights the A3 is the move
to defend it but kramniku goes Knights
to E1 it's very rare only been played
like four times in top tier games and as
I understand it mostly by Russian
players uh Knight to F6 and now Pawn to
C3 kicking away the Knight Knight goes
back and now akramnik develops by
pinning the Knight with Bishop to G5 we
have Bishop to E7 and now Knight to D2
continuing development and now there is
a game where castles was played but Hans
plays Knight to the E4 and it is now
already as of move 9 that we have a
completely new game so offering a lot of
Trades here night for night Bishop for
Bishop and while chronic does trade on
E7 Bishop captures Queen capture C just
plays F3 he wants to kick away the
Knight and then grab the full center
with Ponte E4 so okay hunts trades with
captures captures uh and castles Queen
side so now we have castles on opposite
sides of the board as the economic
already played G3 and F3 and those pawns
will be Target for uh Hans uh Hans soon
to be advancing pawns so Pawn to E4 and
the bishop back to G6 with Knight to D3
now an excellent score for the Knight
and an excellent Center for uh for Comic
but he does have the sort of uh well a
ruined King side uh and of course Hans
wants to hone in on that Target so upon
the H5 and Vladimir stops at Pawn to H4
and now Pawn to E5 the King has been
weakened so it's time to open up the
position e captures on the E5 Rook
captures nicely aligning The Rook with
the queen on D2 and now Pawn to F4
opening up an attack against The Rook
here and Hunt simply plays Pawn to E4
and now you could play this a lot of
different ways the uh the the engine's
favorite choice is Rook after E1 just
pinning the pawn so you cannot take the
Knight and after the pawn is defended
you just continue the attack on the
queen side B5 A4 B4 A4 B5 and so on but
here uh after Pawn to E4 we have Pawn to
F5 chronic sacrifices upon uh obviously
for Rapid development Bishop captures on
F5 Rook 8 to E1 and now Bishop to H7 the
time format as you know is rapid and uh
they have 10 minutes
um each for the game plus two seconds
increment we have Knight to F4 and now
Rook d as The Rook is attacked Rook D
back to d8 and now Knight captures on H5
kramnik wins the pawn back so here we
have Pawn to F5 now defending those
pawns and uh now if you look at the
position uh okay uh a company might have
something here but those Pawns in front
of the king do not look good especially
for a rapid type format so Queen G5 of
course he would very much enjoy a
trading queens and Hans plays Pawn to G6
now he says let's trade and then he will
just enjoy a very nice position and in
fact this is objectively best for
chronic he should just trade and then go
back Knight to F4 and the game continues
okay we want to maybe stop this we're
gonna play Rook D6 but it's a pretty
equal position however after G6 Knight
to F6 was played and now we have Rook
um uh Rook uh Dita f8 now going after
the Knight here and the kramnik has the
trade here we have Knight captures on H7
Queen captures an H7 and now Pawn to D5
continuing to advance
um the d-pawn and then of course C5 C4
C5 is coming Knight to d8 and now Queen
back to E3 trying to grab the A7 Pawn so
of course Han stops it he plays Rook to
B8 and now Pawn to C4 of course now you
want to start advancing those pawns
Knight to F7 as Hans does control all of
these squares the Knight really does
belong on E5 and The Chronic tries to
stop it with Queen to F4 but now Queen
to G7 still preparing Knight to E5 and
now we have Pawn to C5 uh here kramnik
even gives up the uh the D5 Pawn for the
attack or maybe he just wandered it I
have no idea but
um uh it's already a position that's
very hard to play for him Queen to D for
check Queen E3 now criminal first the
queen crate and queen captures on D5
with Rook to D1 now you wanna win some
dampy here and while Hans could go after
the A2 Pawn he does not want to give um
grounding the semi-open a file so he
goes back Queen to E6 and now Pawn to B4
uh we have Knights the E uh sorry
Knights the E5 uh as we we discussed now
the Knight has all of these squares all
depending on what economic plays and
pawn to B5 we have Knight to G4
attacking the queen and queen a D4 and
here is where things get really really
interesting you have to be very careful
because you do have back rank issues yes
the d8 square is guarded twice now by
the two Rooks but that can easily change
and here interestingly Hans played Pawn
to G5 now the top engine move as I'm
sure some of you or all of you are
wondering is Queen to E7 and queen t7
stops all of uh karmonic's ideas of ever
using the default the d8 square to his
advantage while nicely preparing Ponto
G5 without actually leaving white any
useful moves but Hans went for the
immediate Pawn to G5 as this is rapid
time format you don't want to give your
opponent too much time to think and
Bishop to H3 is the move you kind of
have to play here although your position
is still really bad uh economic played
age captures on G5 and now hans's
position is completely winning but it's
not uh it's not clear how and why it's
completely winning now I could make this
uh uh moment like I pause the video
moment because I was planning another
one but I could make this one and
another one just uh to make it more
realistic for you feel free to pause the
video and try to find the absolute best
move for Hans while I give you a couple
of seconds
uh so for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on of course
figuring out you have to somehow reach
the H2 square with the queen and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Queen to G8 which is not the
move hands played Hans played Queen to
G6 which kind of has the same idea uh
only uh you know In the Heat of the
battle it uh kind of misses a few uh
intricacies of The Possession now the
reason why Queen to G8 is much much
better uh is that
um well you you never have to worry
about Queen to d8 uh that's the that's
the whole point not not about Queen
today The Surreal thread is Bishop
characters on e4 and then F captures
you're gonna trade a pair of Rooks and
then you're gonna play Queen to d8
sacrifice the queen and Checkmate the
black king even the black queen is not
also guarding the back rank so this is
what happened when Hans played Queen to
G6 he still has the idea of going for
Queen to H2 but now he does not have
control over the back Rank and now if
kramnik found Bishop captures on e4 he's
still in the game I'm gonna show it as
he did not find it Bishop captures an an
E4 and now you cannot capture if you
capture we already said you trade a pair
of Rooks you sacrifice sorry sacrifice
the queen and it's a back rank mate so
of course you cannot do that so after
Bishop captures on um E4 you have to
pretend like that never happened you
have to play Queen to H5 and now you are
threatening this beautiful Checkmate
here but just Rook D2 and now look at
this bishop covers uh this diagonal the
root covers the H2 Square You're Gonna
Play Queen H3 go after the pawn and now
you have to play Bishop to F3 it's silly
but that's how you have to do it again
with the threat of Bishop captures on G4
so Queen captures in G3 check and now
Rook to G2
again Queen H4 going for uh Checkmate on
H1 now again you move the rook and the
bishop covers the H1 Square uh sorry uh
you you move the Rook to E2 and now uh
everything is uh everything is very nice
you can go for a repetition or you could
go for Queen captures and G5 and hope to
survive this so maybe black wins this
but it is definitely yeah economic is
the best choice which of course would
not be possible head hunts played with
the top engine will Queen to G6 but here
comic just played Pawn to B6 and now his
position falls apart Queen to H5 now
kramnik is not in time for anything Pawn
captures on C7 and now you have to
capture if you don't then you run into
trouble so hunt captures Queen to D6
check King to C8 and now Rook F to E1
the problem is if you go Queen to D7
check yes you can give two more checks
but after King day eight uh there is no
uh continuation there are no more checks
there are no threats here it's a game
over for economics so here Rook fd1 was
played freeing of the F1 Square for the
king but it is far from enough to
survive this queen H2 check King to F1
and now of course the the crushing Point
F4 uh just opening up the f file in
front of the white king so uh currently
does not resign here he actually still
finds uh poison in the position he plays
Queen to E6 with check King to B8 and
now Rook the d8 with check he gives up a
rook to survive the attack Rook captures
and now Queen captures an E4 threatening
Checkmate on B7 but now uh hunt has a
beautiful way of ending the game feel
free to pause the video and try to find
uh the strongest winning move for black
while I give you a couple of seconds
uh so yeah for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on being a
true master of incredible positions And
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it is of course on to F3 this
is what Hans played and he was in this
position on move 43 that of Vladimir
kramnik resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here uh problem
is of course now Checkmate is no longer
an option the bishop is blocked by the
pawn here uh if you play Bishop captures
on F3 then of course Queen to F2 is
Checkmate so that's out of the question
and if Queen captures then you align the
queen nicely with the King and we can
just play Rook H to f8 when the White
Queen and of course that's it so uh
cramney did not wait for this after Pawn
to F3 he resigned and a wonderful
wonderful victory for Hans mokia Neiman
in round one of their AI cop match and
what happened in uh game two was that uh
of course now Hans had the white pieces
and he dominated the game completely
from my perspective as I understand it
uh and in the end it was is a drawn Rook
end game it was a queen and Rook end
game then Queens got traded off and then
in a completely equal Rook end game uh
kravnik was just playing much much
slower the game ended with Hans having
more than two minutes on the clock and
the ceramic blundered um uh the the
position people under the pawn and then
it was game over with some three seconds
on the clock so it was a 2-0 victory for
Hans he eliminated kramnik and he goes
up uh in in the division uh so that's
what happened in this game now I haven't
seen the one uh that kramney lost to a
feeding Master on on chess.com but I if
you guys really want that we can check
that one as well but uh kromnic and Hans
had their fair share of differences
online and this is if you guys haven't
seen it uh this is what uh Hans replied
to to kranika on his own Twitter profile
so let's check it out
um I just first of all want to say that
I I'm a huge fan of your chess and I've
been following your career and you've
been someone that I've looked up to for
a very long time
I saw your recent videos and I thought
that perhaps a resolution to that would
be to have an in-person training camp
where you'd be able to evaluate my chest
on a deeper level and uh I'd be happy to
um do whatever you like play games look
at positions uh and you could get a more
nuanced
um
understanding of my interesting style
that you have talked about extensively
so please let me know I I'd be
anytime I'm not playing a tournament I
could do it any time anywhere
um completely up to you and of course I
could compensate you for your time as
well as I would expect for any coaching
that you would do
so uh um please consider it you can
reach out to me anywhere and um
I hope this uh
is an interesting proposition for you
so there you have it that is the
proposition it's hard to say what
kramnik will decide but I'm gonna go
with uh yeah not very likely although
who knows so what do you think about
this what do you think about kramnik's
ideas uh is the Chess World simply too
full of cheaters or is there something
else going on do you have such
experiences playing online do you face
cheaters a lot I can't really say I mean
I've um of course I'm not playing on
that level but the the you know the the
the the quantity that I play I play
mostly bullet and Blitz I can't really
say I've ever had a problem of
encountering a cheater when someone
crushes me with a brilliancy uh I'm I'm
actually very happy and uh uh mostly
it's because I play really really really
bad but when you're a former world
champion and you just get uh you know
owned like this so it's I guess it's a
bit of a bit of a different story and
yeah it's um a rapid time format so you
know when he's playing a force rapid and
Blitz now it's much much harder than
let's say 10 years ago because everyone
is so well versed in all of these engine
lines so uh you never know you really
never know what to expect even though in
this game like it's chronic who went out
of theory very very early on okay
chronic played uh Hans played this
Knight before but then uh account did
not go for this standard Knight A3 he
played for Knight D1 and I don't know I
I I can say of course Hans uh hans's
Theory knowledge I'm sure is vast I
don't know if it would cover an it1 line
but you know you've seen what happened
and he he got a very nice game out of it
uh so yeah that's the game and a little
bit of extra info on the subject hope
you enjoyed that I'd like to thank Kim
dolman uh kavi halimadi Raymond young
graysonjustfestival.org.gg and Ellen
Soul Hearts then for your contribution
to my channel I don't think a lot to
really appreciate it as usual you can
check to my previous videos here thank
you for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on you one of the
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day and if you still uh want uh
to try your luck and skill at playing
galireza in our upcoming event next
month first link in the description
below see you soon